go back to christmas meals they're going
back to christmas meals um
i used to [ __ ] hate christmas meals
because my my parents used to make they
honestly they probably still do [ __ ]
awful gravy it's like jelly
ew yeah i feel like christmas meals
live and die by the quality of gravy
it's true because
i used to eat all of the components on
their own yeah because i i refuse to eat
my parents gravy and the whole family
was like what's wrong connor why are you
doing it
it tastes good what do you mean i'm like
no the kfc gravy although not great
tastes better than this [ __ ] it's the
consistency anything that's jelly i
don't like
okay there's there's like a perfect
noodle right because if it's too jelly
it's it's basically like a solid it
should not be yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but like
it if it's like i've had liquidy
nothing more depressing than watery
gravy you know right you when you pour
that [ __ ] in if it splashes it's
it's too big yeah like it needs to like
mold but not be like
jelly like yeah i'm calling you out mom
okay question then for you guys
do you guys like eggnog i've never heard
that i have tried it once i am not a fan
we don't have eggnog
mailing just turned around and mainly do
you like eggnog
melon melon just sims for eggs you said
japanese
yeah i never used to like eggnog but
then like two christmases ago when i
went home my aunt
like handmade eggnog right and you have
that with like uh
i just i just they just sound good it's
just it's it's like do you like custard
i okay it's okay it's basically think of
custard but it's a drink
oh god yeah yeah oh yeah yeah and then
and then and then my friend
introduced me to eggnog with uh fireball
and usually i don't [ __ ] with fireball i
think i think fireball is overrated as
[ __ ] but
that with eggnog is like it's so good
i only like custard with like apple pie
or something right something like
you can have an apple but i think
custard on its own doesn't sound good i
like it with a solid to like help
well that's why you have it with the
christmas meal oh jesus christ
i've been trying to find eggnog in japan
because i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] i do
not i just doesn't sound good like it
doesn't sound like
i'll try it right that's the thing
though like the word eggnog is the least
like appealing sounding word you know
what i mean
it sounds like a dirty porno
eggnog my favorite porn
sounds gross i don't know i just
i i feel like because my family's like
mega british
right christmas meals to me have been
like the same for like a [ __ ]
as probably this they were a thousand
years ago yeah just people awkwardly
sitting around a table being like yes
did you like your presents
i did like my presents mother should we
open a cracker do you have crackers in
australia
christmas crackers oh you mean like
white people like yeah
oh all those crackers yeah christmas
crackers
do you have those in america the
christmas crackers that you pull is that
is that part of the american
you both pull an end of this cracker
yeah yeah and then and then whoever gets
the bigger half gets the [ __ ]
it's like a kinder egg it's like a
kinder egg but like
but you pop it open and then there's
little things that like little plastic
toys and stuff and there's always like
one
really [ __ ] joke yeah and you have a
paper crown
america doesn't have this huh oh my god
no america doesn't have that yeah well
you're uncultured you'd pull one of
those they're overpriced they're like
ten dollars for a pack of ten
and it's [ __ ] and it's over in like 30
seconds yeah when you're like five
you're like
this is [ __ ] amazing yeah like this
is like death note levels of like mind
games but then you realize six crowns
but then but then you realize they're
rigged in one end and then when you
start cheating you realize that because
you when you when you're the one who's
supposed to lose and you just grab the
whole thing and then they pull
and you realize it's not happening and
you're like [ __ ] i i've been caught out
here
i've cheated okay uh do you guys have um
you guys have advent calendars right
yeah apparently in america it's not a
thing is it not
no i've heard in some parts in a lot of
parts of america advent calendars are
not a thing
i hated them yeah i never got them i i
never got them
i don't like the idea of being teased
for like 25 days on chocolate just give
me the whole [ __ ] it's
like it's not even a ball like like like
it's like a small amount
like so to me like advent to explain
advent calendar calendars for anyone who
doesn't know so you get a calendar at
the beginning of december
and every day you can open up like a day
of the week
and you get a different piece of
chocolate white people and like as
as a kid as a kid i was just like this
is
as a kid it was just like the equivalent
of no not the red mill or just for
chocolate you know what i mean it is the
most blue balls
like christmas okay also when do you
decide to eat the chocolate
is it the morning thing or is it an
evening thing to me i always thought it
was the morning
first thing in the morning you get you
it was like as a kid it was it was the
only time you could eat chocolate it was
first thing in the morning it was but it
always like threw off my vibe right
sounds like why am i [ __ ] eating
chocolate this morning i don't know why
i don't know why it's a thing in
australia because it's christmas for us
is in like the middle of the summer
you buy it and it's just like the you
can see the chocolate kind of melting
from like inside the thing he just opens
like
let's go did you guys have like the the
expensive ones are like the wooden ones
right
there never [ __ ] buy me the expensive
wooden advent calendars
the the traditional oh my god the
traditional wood like the traditional
advent calendars i've seen is like
it's like a wooden thing and then you
open this like wooden door to like open
the chocolate my mom like refused to pay
more than like a dollar for mine
yeah so she would always wait until like
december 4th
to get it and i remember being like
three days of exploring
chocolate yeah mom i see you i see what
you're doing here
i i don't know if it's like a mental
thing but for some reason to me
advent calendar chocolate just tasted
better and i don't know why
like it's i i have exactly the same
opinions about easter egg chocolates
i have no idea why you know why it's
because it's the same cadbury's
chocolate as soon as you put it in egg
format it tastes ten times better to me
i don't i don't know why
i used to agree because i had an advent
calendar like three years ago yeah
and i was like oh fantastic i'm gonna be
a kid again because i had one in like
three years
yeah and i ate it and i'm like wow this
is just [ __ ] like this is [ __ ] and so i
just ate it all in one go i put them
all out on like december 5th i grabbed
them all out put them in my hands did
you guys have the ones where
you kind of like it like cracks out like
a medicine yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it's okay getting
back to easter chocolate right yeah
i think it's because you're a kid
because i you know when you're a kid
right did they have these in australia
where they had
so in the uk they have the standard like
one dollar two dollar yeah
eggs right maybe you get a chocolate bar
as well yeah right
but when you're a kid you'd always see
the big egg right
i feel like the magic is lost when you
know you can buy it because i
my parents my parents were never gonna
buy me the thirty dollar
they would never buy me more than one x
i'm like yeah you don't need more than
that that's ridiculous like
and so when i was like two years ago i
bought the big egg right but it was
reduced for like 10 bucks
yeah and i had it thinking it was going
to be [ __ ] like god tier experience
came with its own shitty mug and two
chocolate bars it was just [ __ ]
shitty chocolate it was just it was
awful i was like wow
i'm the opposite and then i realized
when i put all this chocolate down
it was like 300 grams of chocolate and i
could have bought like inside
right because i could have bought like
five times the amount of chocolate
than what i paid we're [ __ ] pain out
the ass for them to put it in a [ __ ]
mold
and just [ __ ] sear it together you
kidding me because the thing is
my my logically my mind knows this
but every time it's easter like even as
an adult
like now that i am an adult i just buy
one i use it on the same day which
which is what something i could never do
before right and then like the next day
i i'm in my local tescos or something
i'm like
i go for another easter egg i can do it
and the thing is crack another one and
the thing is i always buy like the
cadburys ones so
they always have like the the chocolate
so it's always like cadbury's buttons or
something and i know
like i can taste that it's exactly the
same chocolate i don't know
something about it's something about
easter eggs it's just like the right
thickness it's just it's just something
about eating an easter egg that just
makes you feel like a king i
i actually preferred the ones that were
like shaped out like a rabbit
yeah those are pretty good yeah those
are good
ones those ones like thick as well yeah
something maybe it's not just easter
eggs something about eating hollow
chocolates that just
i just hit different in my mind i don't
i don't know
i don't know why i don't know about that
one i don't i don't know
what is wrong with my psychology to be
like chocolate bar get that [ __ ] away
hollow chocolate oh okay let me let me
nibble on this